ce samedi après-midi dans les rues de
moscou l'ours emblème de la russie et de
sortir
aujourd'hui nous organisons une classe
ouverte pour les enfants
l'animal est là pour accueillir une
vingtaine d'enfants âgés de 8 à 12 ans
ils viennent de faire trois heures de
bus pour prendre une leçon de
patriotisme
c'est un vétéran de l'armée rouge qui
joue les professeurs
rappelez vous qui vous a donné la vie
qui a défendu notre pays contre les
ennemis
souvenez-vous
et transmettez le à vos enfants
pendant un quart d'heure l'ancien soldat
rappelle la résistance héroïque de la
russie pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
une banale sortie scolaire a priori et
pourtant toute la presse occidentale est
présente car ce petit cours en pleine
rue n'est pas organisé par n'importe qui
il est étroitement encadré par ses
hommes en veste rouge tous appartiennent
à un mouvement de jeunesse très
controversé les nachi en russe les
nôtres
depuis trois ans ces jeunes sont surtout
les fros la rue et à eux
leurs forces réussir à mobiliser jusqu'à
cent mille personnes des rassemblements
monstres au service exclusif d'un seul
homme le maître du kremlin et vladimir
poutine
[Musique]
avec leurs slogans patriotiques ils
battent le pavé sur la place rouge et
revendiquent publiquement d'être le bras
armé du pouvoir
aujourd'hui nous sommes une nouvelle
armée
dans le même temps voilà le sort réservé
aux opposants
[Applaudissements]
alors que les nachi sont les bienvenus
sur la place rouge ceux qui osent élever
la voix contre le kremlin sont évacués
manu militari
[Musique]
qui sont ces jeunes fanatiques de
poutine pour la plupart les nachi sont
des urbains issus de milieux plutôt
favorisés beaucoup sont étudiants comme
svetlana 20 ans ce jour-là elle organise
une manifestation
ce sont mes contacts des listes des
listes des listes il faut que j'aille
les données
la plupart des militants dispose d'un
portable payé par le mouvement afin que
chacun puisse être prévenu des actions
même au dernier moment pour cette
manifestation décider du jour au
lendemain se fait là n'a réussi à
convaincre une vingtaine de militants
c'est bon
merci les amis allez on y va camarades
ce fait la mène la troupe elle n'est pas
n'importe qui je suis l'une des
commissaires du mouvement c'est pas
facile de le devenir
voilà je vous montre mon estime de
commissaire
on se croirait revenu au temps des
soviets chez les nachi la hiérarchie la
même que celle qu'utilisaient les
anciennes jeunesses communistes
le grade le plus élevé celui de ce fait
la nar commissaire et dans la russie de
poutine un grade pareil ouvre toutes les
portes
à l'eau qui a l'autorisation pour
rentrer sergei
s'ils manifestent aussi facilement c'est
que les nachi ont des contacts très haut
placé
voici le document
j'ai l'accord de la mairie
ici je suis en contact direct avec le
ministère de l'intérieur
et pour leur démonstration de force les
nachi emploie les grands moyens ce jour
là c'est une manifestation pour
protester contre les critiques de
l'union européenne à leur égard et pour
grossir les rangs le mouvement a affrété
des bus qui sont allés chercher des
manifestants dans les banlieues les plus
éloignés
les bus ce n'est pas nous qui payons on
a des sponsors des entreprises qui nous
financent
elles apprécient nos actions elle paye
notre organisation elle paye les bus
donc compagnies pétrolières ce sont les
entreprises proches du pouvoir qui
financent leurs activités
les nachi ce sont des jeunes gens
modernes et très organisés
pour diffuser leurs idées ils ont
recours aux techniques les plus en
pointe du marketing politique
[Musique]
au quartier général des nachi dans le
centre de moscou
nikita broad inco est un des leaders du
mouvement
à peine plus âgé que ses militants à 27
ans il supervise toutes les actions des
nachi
un peu partout dans qg du rouge et du
blanc couleurs de la russie éternelle
les nachi ont même lancé une ligne de
produits dérivés dont voici le showroom
ici les filles peuvent fantasmer sur nos
vêtements aux couleurs de notre drapeau
par exemple les filles commissaire aime
bien porter les couleurs des patriotes
nikita veut nous montrer que chez les
nachi l'engagement patriotique et total
jusqu'au moindre détail il prend comme
exemple string le mouvement recommande
aux filles de ne pas emporter pour une
raison assez inattendu
la question de la croissance
démographique est très importante pour
la russie et aussi pour toute l'europe
il ya quelque chose qui est confirmée de
manière pressante ific c'est que le
string facilite certaines maladies et
empêchent les femmes d'avoir des enfants
les nachi sont tous bénévoles et ils ne
comptent pas leurs heures comme alice 20
ans qui travaille au service de presse
du mouvement un lieu stratégique l'image
et internet la communication
c'est l'une des forces du mouvement mais
il ya aussi la bonne vieille propagande
à l'ancienne un petit livre rouge
c'est ce livre compose tous les idées il
y en à pois c'est la bible du mouvement
trois grandes idées moderniser le pays
éduquer les jeunes et redonner toute sa
place à la russie
la parole de vladimir poutine est
omniprésente son image aussi
poutine c'est la force la puissance
l'amour sincère pour son pays le
patriotisme ardent et puissant
pour moi c'est une personnalité très
puissante îles à sion l'espace de huit
ans donner un nouvel élan à notre pays
après trois ans d'existence les nachi
sont aujourd'hui présents un peu partout
en russie il recrute en permanence et
cela commence dès le plus jeune âge ce
jour là alice se rend à vladimir à 180
km de moscou c'est dans cette ville de
350 mille habitants que l'étudiante a
grandi alice est attendu à l'école
numéro 40 elle veut nous montrer le
programme des nachi destiné aux
tout-petits à peler les miches cas les
oursons elle retrouve des membres locaux
du mouvement qui vont animer un jeu de
piste but de l'exercice devenir le chef
au sein d'un groupe
nous voulons que vous jouiez dans la rue
vous allez pouvoir construire un petit
perry est le meilleur d'entre vous
deviendra le président
on leur dit président plutôt que chef
parce que président c'est le mot qui
évoque le plus l'autorité ici
voilà ce que les oursons doivent
apprendre devenir des petits poutine à 9
ans ici pourtant il est interdit de
parler politique à l'école mais la
maîtresse ne vois pas où est le mal
je suis là pour éviter toute propagande
politique
je suis leur mettra ses jeux sur rails
mais là quand même c'est de la politique
non pas du tout de quelle politique
peut-on parler avec des enfants de 9 ans
les nachi recrute donc belle berceau et
dès qu'ils en ont l'occasion ils
relayent le nouvel ordre moral prônée
par poutine
nous les retrouvons devant une épicerie
à qui il reproche d'avoir vendu de
l'alcool à des mineurs
en russie c'est interdit par la loi et
les nachi s'érige en milice populaire
nous voulons une nation scène des
enfants si la police ne peut pas
s'occuper de tout
jouer les redresseurs de torts les nachi
ce sont capables d'aller encore beaucoup
plus loin
comme il y à chine membre du parti
libéral un mouvement d'opposition il a
déjà eu affaire aux jeunesses
poutiniennes
les nachi sabotent les actions de
l'opposition
ils ont une rhétorique très agressive
il persécute les opposants du kremlin
on vous rentrez chez vous le soir vous
pouvez tomber sur des gens qui vous
attendent près de votre bord et vous
tabasse en expliquant qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas continuer de faire ce que vous
faites
les nachi font la propagande du
président et il contribue à étouffer
l'opposition vladimir poutine sait se
montrer reconnaissant envers ses jeunes
supporters
ici au parlement d'anciens h ils ont
déjà atteint le sommet du pouvoir comme
sergei vélo connaît fin des trois
députés issus des jeunesses poutiniennes
et dans l'antichambre de son bureau à la
douma ce sont d'autres nachi qui
attendent leur tour leur avenir semble
prometteur
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui il y a déjà des centaines de
nos activistes qui occupent des postes
importants dans des structures du
gouvernement et dans d'importantes
compagnies privées
pour nous il n'ya que le soutien du
président qui compte et croient en nous
non pas parce que nous le défendons
parce que nous sommes la nuit ce pays
les petits soldats de poutine attendent
sans crainte le résultat de l'élection
présidentielle
le parti au pouvoir est donné largement
gagnant et c'est en partie grâce à leur
action les nachi le savent la rue et à
eux et pour longtemps encore